so i'm really excited to welcome dr
joseph scalise here today
dr scalise is currently a visiting
fellow at the saw sweetheart southeast
asia center at the london school of
economics and political science and he
specializes in the history of
revolutionary movements and
authoritarianism in southeast asia with
a focus on the post-war philippines
he's a very prolific scholar since
completing his phd in southeast asian
studies at uc berkeley my alma mater by
the way where i did my ba
where he completed his phd there in 2018
at uc berkeley he has published no fewer
than eight peer-reviewed journal
articles
including but not all of them i'll say
just the most recent ones um in 2021 i
guess forthcoming still a deliberately
forgotten battle the la
mangagawa and the manila port strike of
1963 and coming out in the journal of
southeast asian studies
2021 again cadre as informal diplomats
ferdinand marcos in the soviet bloc 1965
through 1974
that's in history and anthropology and
also in 2021 this year the geopolitical
alignments of diverging social interest
the sino-soviet split in the partido
comunista in filipinas 1966-67
in critical asian studies
he also has a book manuscript under
contract with cornell university press
it's called the drama of dictatorship
martial law and the communist parties of
the philippines which should be coming
out probably in a year or so
and
a whole slew of book chapters published
reviews and a lot of wonderful things
for everyone to look up and start
reading immediately
i won't say more because we're going to
learn a lot from the talk and hopefully
we'll have a great q a after this but
please join me in welcoming dr joseph
scalise to our virtual brown bag series
his talk today is entitled the
geopolitical alignments of diverging
social interests the sino-soviet split
in the philippines please take it away
joseph thank you very much eric i
appreciate the introduction i appreciate
the opportunity to uh address the
audience on a topic that i think is
really exciting which is to say the
sino-soviet split in the periphery not
in the core disputants of the soviet
union and china but in uh throughout the
global south in particular and the
philippines as a case study
uh
the listeners may have noted that the
topic of the talk uh the geopolitical
alignment of diverging social interest
corresponds with the title of an article
published earlier this year in critical
asian studies i'm expanding upon that
article towards uh what is a second book
proposal that i've recently submitted
i have a forthcoming book with cornell
university press which i hope will be
out next year uh on the subject of
martial law and the role played by two
rival communist parties which i've
entitled the drama of dictatorship
uh it's an extraordinarily heated and
exciting uh and terrifying development
from 1969 to 1972
as all of the various factions of the
ruling elite are angling for
uh one in one way or another
authoritarian rule uh and two rival
parties uh two rival communist parties
tied to moscow and beijing played a
critical role in this um and that's what
my book documents
but it raises inevitably a question
why were there two communist parties
and not one
and why were they what were their
allegiances to this dispute between
china and the soviet union and that is
what i'm attempting to explore in this
talk and uh in
my second book which i have submitted
the book proposal for which i've
entitled aligned rivalries the
sino-soviet split from the periphery and
the question that occupies me is how was
it
that the political rivalries in the
philippines and throughout the global
south throughout what i'm calling the
periphery to this dispute
how was it that they aligned with
uh the interests of moscow and beijing
of the soviet union and china um
and i'm trying to avoid narratives that
either imply that it was uh
the product of external machinations
effectively the argument of the right
that these were agents of the soviet
union or china or what i find to be an
equally
a dead end scholarly is that these were
the product of domestic disputes and
really had nothing to do with
international communism uh that as i
will demonstrate in a moment that
argument simply does not hold up
um
so that then is the origins of this talk
uh and uh i'm going to be examining the
role of the philippine communist party
and why it was that it split along the
lines of the sino-soviet dispute there's
been very little written upon this topic
uh the question of why in the 1960s
uh in 1966 to 67 in particular the
philippine communist party partido
communist
split into
and out of this
uh
emerged a new communist party the
communist party of the philippines cpp
and so
while the names are simply tagalog and
english and mean the same thing for our
purposes
in this talk
the pkp the tagalog name the older party
uh is the one that allied with moscow
and the cpp uh which still exists to
this day
uh and is a strong political influence
to this day is the party that was
founded in 1968 69 and allied with
beijing with china so the pkp and the
cpp but throughout the first half of the
1960s there was but one party the pkp
and the question is why did it split in
60 c7 what led to this and how do we
account for the fact that it
corresponded to the sino-soviet dispute
in a way that is intellectually
satisfying there has been very little
prior scholarship on this the most
influential explanation was not even
published it's an unpublished paper
delivered i believe in canberra the anu
by a man named francisco namenzo dodon
lomenzo very influential intellectual
figure a man who was himself a
leading member of the central committee
of the pkp at the time
and went on to become president of the
university of the philippines and in
1984 he put forward this explanation
the schism was not a local expression of
the international dispute between the
soviet and chinese parties but the
offshoot of a generational rift between
the remnants of an aborted rebellion
i'll get to that in a moment and the new
elements who were spared the trauma of
defeat
so on the one hand these remnants of the
hook rebellion which i'll talk about in
a sec and these newer layers the youth
who came into the party and were spared
the trauma of the defeat of the hook
rebellion that he argues is the seeds of
the split
but
since it occurred at the height of the
sino-soviet dispute what was a domestic
quarrel
assumed an international dimension
neither the communist party of the
soviet union nor the communist party of
china were initially involved their
interventions which came later
aggravated rather than triggered the
conflict now i seen the menzo's
intervention in 1984 as something of a
salutary contribution despite the fact
that i fundamentally disagree with it he
was pushing back against the standard
narrative
that
put forward by the right and agents of
the state and the marcos dictatorship
this is still the reign of ferdinand
marcos in 1984
that the split
and the allegiance of the rival parties
was a product of external agents
external machinations that these were
effectively agents of foreign powers and
he's saying no this was a domestic
dispute
but it is not i argue convincing or
intellectually satisfying on a number of
levels one it cannot account for the
extraordinary
simultaneity of this
in which parties around the globe in
latin america in india and new zealand
and australia etc all of them split
within years of each other along the
same lines
there is a sort of nationalist myopia to
this argument that sees this as a
domestic dispute
and so while the pushback against the
argument of agents is a healthy one
the alternative that is posited a
domestic dispute that took on
international coloration
is unsatisfying what is more the idea of
a generational rift
does not hold up to scrutiny
many of the older layers who had been
tied to a peasant rebellion in the 1950s
known as the hook rebellion which was
defeated
many of these older layers in fact gave
their support to the new cpp allied to
the chinese communist party
and
in the same fashion the majority of the
party's youth
who did not go through the sting of
defeat
remained tied to the pkp the majority
including nomenzo himself who was a man
of the same youth as those who broke
from the party to found the cpp
the argument doesn't hold up on a number
of levels
finally there is the claim that the
dispute was simply won over violence
this is not a scholarly argument so much
as a common conception the cpp advocated
armed struggle the pkp opposed it this
again is fundamentally wrong the pkp had
an armed wing just as much as the cpp
did and then armed wayne carried out
guerilla struggle and bombings this was
not the divide what was
what accounts for this alignment of
interest between the soviet union and
the pkp
the cpp and china as well as with rival
factions of the elite and how do we
account for the simultaneous tenanty of
the sino-soviet split
i
am inspired in this by something that i
was reading over dinner as you read
other scholars from other fields and i
was reading brodel and rodell wrote in
his book out of italy
of the dialectic of the internal and
external of the italian renaissance and
he noted that it is sometimes said that
light shed from the margin is the best
that a complex hole may best be
apprehended from its outer limits
in a situation in which every fact
every event has been minutely studied by
the generations of devoted historians
the vantage point of the periphery
of diaspora can provide new clarity to
developments in the core now i find this
particularly useful for examining the
sino-soviet split uh the development of
global maoism the development of
international communism from the vantage
point of the core disputants has been
meticulously analyzed
what i would argue
has been
seriously understudied
is
that this was an integrated
international phenomenon
and the periphery that is to say parties
around the globe
split along the lines of the sino-soviet
dispute not as some form of collateral
damage blowback an unintended
consequence of a dispute between two
national entities but rather as a
product of a s of a coherent
integrated international whole
and that by viewing the sino-soviet
dispute from the periphery we can gain
new insight not only into the disputes
within the periphery itself
but to the development of global maoism
to the character of the global cold war
and to the nature of the dispute between
moscow and beijing in the 1950s 1960s
and 1970s
at the core
of my argument
is the claim
that stalinism
is it's a number of things this term but
among them is
a coherent political program i think
most commonly in everyday parliaments we
associate the word stalinism uh
correctly with the brutal excesses of
the bureaucracy under stalin and also
under mao uh
responsible for purges
uh for the gulag uh for
uh the revision and rewriting of history
etc all of the things that we associate
i think with the name orwell etc
these things are true but i argue that
they are
necessary manifestations of a core
political program
and by examining this program we see
that there is in fact a fundamental
continuity between stalinism and maoism
and that maoism i would argue is
not something separate from but is a
variant of
stalinism under particular social
circumstances
what then is this political program well
i break it down into four very simple
points socialism in one country a
two-stage theory of revolution and the
block of four classes these were the
programmatic nature of stalinism you can
see here the artwork of the communist
party of the philippines produced in the
1970s that shows the block of four
classes i'll get back to that in just a
moment to explain this illustration
stalinism at its essence expressed the
political interests of privileged layers
of the party bureaucracy within the
soviet union and after 1949 in china
seeking to defend and expand the social
basis of their positions these
bureaucrats put forward a nationalist
program of building socialism in one
country as the paramount political task
rather than world socialist revolution
looking to secure diplomatic and trade
relations in service to the construction
of their national economies
stalin's bureaucrats sought political
capital with which to negotiate with a
ruling class in countries around the
world
to this end they rehabilitated the old
menshevik line of a two-state revolution
they instructed communist parties around
the globe that the tasks of the
revolution in which they were engaged
were not yet socialist in character
but were national and democratic only
a section of the capitalist class they
argued would play a progressive role in
this necessary first stage so the tasks
in this first stage of a two-stage
revolution the national democratic stage
still have a capitalist character
and therefore a section of the
capitalist class will play a progressive
role that's the argument
the goal of communist party leaders
should thus be to secure an alliance
with this progressive section of the
national bourgeoisie and to bring the
pressure and support of a mass movement
behind their elite allies now this is
what we see in the illustration this uh
is from a book on how to use drawing to
instruct the masses and you can see on
the top layer
the enemies and the enemies are uncle
sam the imperialist united states the
comprador bourgeoisie that the fat
capitalist up top and the landlord
but on the bottom we see the block of
four classes
and this is comprised of friends malachi
began mangagawa the worker
some of these hardly require translation
that's the petty bourgeoisie and
that is to say the national bourgeoisie
these are the four progressive classes
and notice that a section of the
capitalist class is by this definition
progressive an ally of the workers
a section of the bosses is an ally of
the workers that's the critical point
in this first stage of a two-stage
revolution
stalinism was first and foremost a
political program that articulated the
interests of the ruling party
bureaucracies before it was denounced by
khrushchev in his 56th secret speech as
show trials purges in the cult of the
great leader
at its essence it was a program before
it was these other things
these were the mechanisms routinely
employed by stalinism to maintain a
bureaucratic hold on power but they were
not the essence of what was disseminated
around the globe the global strength of
stalinism rested on the appeal to a
layer of nationalist intellectuals in
countries of belated capitalist
development of its core concepts
socialism in one country a two-stage
theory of revolution and the block of
four progressive classes
many communist party leaders outside of
the soviet union were drawn to stalinism
because they saw this as a means of
implementing national reforms
it allowed them
to deploy the banner of marxism
and use it to win mass support for
industrialization under native
capitalist ownership
so the program of national reforms
national industrialization the
development of a sort of authoric
national capitalist economy
very much a core concept of nationalist
intelligence in the 1950s and 60s
required
mass enthusiasm
to carry it out
but how do you secure the support of
workers and peasants for what
effectively is a series of protectionist
measures on behalf of national
capitalism
it amounts to trickle-down economics if
we can improve national capitalism it
will
float rising tide floats all boats that
sort of logic i mean this is of course
long before reagan but that's the
argument and the answer is that
stalinism provides
you can use the banner of marxism
of revolution etc to dress up the first
stage of a necessary two-stage
revolution as progressive and an
alliance with the capitalist class
loans from and trade with the soviet
bloc were an additional measure and
furtherance to these ends
it was for this reason that the pkp as
i'll detail in just a moment gave it
support to ferdinand marcos in 1965
proclaiming him the progressive
representative of the national
bourgeoisie
this is a year prior to the split in the
communist party
there was a contradiction however at the
heart of this stalinist program
that contradiction is that it sought
simultaneously
to retain hold over
a mass movement and to secure an
alliance with a section of the elite it
sought to do both
it was inevitable that it had to do both
its alliance with a section of the elite
was predicated upon its hold over a mass
movement that was its political capital
under situations of social unrest
however this contradiction became
increasingly unstable
hard to hold together
how do you retain hold over a mass
movement and an alliance with an with
the elite in a situation that is
becoming increasingly revolutionary
increasingly explosive
and in the context of the 1960s this
contradiction at the heart of stalinism
tore itself apart diverging social
interests that found
that the ideological form of the
national dispute between the soviet
union and china
gave expression to these diverging
social interests an alignment between
this program and its variance with
diverging interests at a national level
this is what i'm going to establish in a
sort of the case study of the
philippines
why what were the variants of the soviet
union in china this is my last point
under stalinism the soviet union and
china were both committed to the
construction of socialism within their
borders and never merged their economies
their divergent national interests
inevitably conflicted
giving rise to rivalry
then open split and armed conflict
the uneven economic development of the
two countries
and their starkly different geopolitical
circumstances fueled the tensions
between them
situated behind the buffer zone of
eastern europe and with a fairly stable
industrial base the soviet union
followed a policy of peaceful
coexistence with the united states and
established friendly ties with autocrats
when suharto rose to power in
1965-66 as we'll see in a moment the
soviet union uh
met with adam malik his foreign minister
and arranged for the repayment of arms
uh that the soviet union had supplied to
the indonesian stadium that had been
used in suppressing the pki
relations with autocrats
the china in contrast found itself by
the mid-1960s threatened on all sides
facing an imminent threat posed by the
u.s invasion of vietnam 1965 and the
loss of its largest international ally
the party comunis indonesia the pki
again 1965.
and the chinese communist party sought
to whip up armed struggle throughout the
region to diffuse the threat of u.s
imperialism to china's immense imperiled
borders
while the soviet government embraced
suharto
the ccp promoted protracted people's war
and armed uprising throughout the
countryside of the world backed by china
the yemen of world revolution now this
was not universally the position of
chinese maoism this was put forward by
lin yao in 1964-65
became the policy of the chinese
communist party in this period and was
abandoned in the early 1970s as china
reoriented and established relations
with the united states but for this
brief window from 65
to 71
in the limbial phase of maoism seen from
the periphery
we have
uh
all of the hallmarks of what became
international maoism
the pkp in the wake of the defeat of the
hook rebellion
was
at the beginning of the 1960s a dormant
political party it had
essentially disappeared from the
political landscape as a result of this
defeat
the re-emergence of the pkp was a direct
result of connections established with
indonesia here the immensely influential
pki the largest communist party outside
of the communist bloc played a critical
role in the dissemination of the ideas
of the sino-soviet split throughout the
region and i substantiate this in great
length uh in the book manuscript that
i'm currently working on the ties with
uh
with indonesia between indonesia and the
philippines and how this played an
instrumental role in the dispute that
shaped island southeast asia known as
confrontation in the period of 1963 to
1965.
the philippines actually was a core
disputant something that has been
largely overlooked by subsequent
scholarship which has seen this as a
national dispute between malaysia and
indonesia over the formation of malaysia
it was in fact a dispute over the social
character of the entire region
the pki through a graduate student in at
the university of the philippines uh
named bakri elias oversaw the rebirth of
the pkp bringing new blood into the
party above all a graduate student from
the university of the philippines named
jose maria
who will go on to become the head of the
newly founded cpp by the end of the
1960s
csun was not immediately however a
dissenter in fact he was the foremost
organizational force within the pkp
instrumental in their support for marcos
in 1965.
he was a core figure and this is the pkp
the tensions that tore apart the party
were not yet present at the beginning of
the 1960s
one of the things that's most
interesting i think in studying the
sino-soviet split from the periphery is
that the model of a sort of hubs and hub
and spokes perspective in which beijing
and moscow are the two hubs and the
spokes reach from beijing to jakarta and
from beijing to manila
is
only partially accurate there was in
fact a complex mesh of relations that
ran from jakarta to manila from havana
to manila uh and from manila to japan
etc
uh these the dissemination of the
sino-soviet tensions spread not only
from the core to the periphery but
throughout the periphery in a somewhat
autonomous fashion
1965 was not only for the purposes of my
study of the sino-soviet split but for
the purposes of world history a global
turning point i don't think this has
been adequately stressed uh in studies
of the 20th century where other turning
points are stressed 1965
with the deployment of u.s troops to
vietnam
in march under operation rolling thunder
by the johnson administration by the end
of the year more than 185 000 u.s forces
were deployed to vietnam and the
crushing of the pki a slaughter hundreds
of thousands possibly upwards of a
million members and supporters of the
pki
uh in the uh rise to power of general
suharto
uh this fundamentally redefined the
region
and world politics and precipitated an
acceleration in the development of
global maoism
uh the turn to the cultural revolution
shifted communist party allegiances the
crushing of the pki was instrumental in
the japanese communist party shifting
it's a lot it's allegiance from beijing
to moscow in 1966
uh it also set in motion the events that
led to the sino-soviet split in the
philippines it was in the wake of 1965
that the philippine communist party was
compelled to seek out new international
relations that were not mediated through
jakarta
in the same year
uh while these events were transpiring
it was a presidential election in the
philippines
ferdinand marcos had recently jumped
ship from his liberal party and joined
the nationalist party and was running as
their presidential candidate against the
incumbent just
the critical question in mobilizing mass
support behind ferdinand marcos was the
question of the war in vietnam
johnson had secretly reached out to
makapagal in 1964 prior to the gulf of
tonkin incident and said that he needed
troops to be deployed to vietnam for an
upcoming surge in u.s troops in the
region
he did the same with thailand korea etc
and makapagal uh declared that he would
wholeheartedly send filipino troops to
vietnam
uh this was going to be known as phil
kag
the philippine civic action group
rather orwellian euphemism for the
troops being deployed to vietnam and
marcos in 1965 denounced makapagal for
doing this claiming that makapagal was
an aspiring dictator words that history
would render ironic um and that he was a
puppet of u.s interests and so on and so
forth and announced that he was opposed
to the deployment of filipino troops to
vietnam
and on this basis the pkp which had been
in an intimate alliance with makapaga
broke with makapaga declared their
support for marcos and campaigned for
him
central to this was jose maria
future head of the cpp
uh csun organized the support from the
youth wing the kapatam
for marcos a fact that he has attempted
subsequently to erase from history
within two weeks
of the election in an interview with
stanley carnell of the washington post
marcos announced
many of us felt that the united states
was preparing to withdraw from vietnam
but now that the united states has
demonstrated this resolute will to slug
it out we've been reassured and he
promised that he would be deploying
filipino troops to vietnam
reversing his stance within
two weeks
interestingly a side note but one can't
help but note marcos's campaign slogan
1965 was that he would quote make the
philippines great again
right-wing populists are not a
particularly imaginative bunch
1967 a memo this sort of sets the tone
for the split in a memo from marshall
wright of the national security council
the national security adviser walt
rossdale he wrote it would be nearly
impossible to overestimate the gravity
of the problems with which our next
ambassador to manila must deal
it has become commonplace for people
knowledgeable on the philippines to
predict a vast social upheaval in the
near future
there is widespread talk that the
current president will be the last
popularly elected philippine chief
executive
there was one more election marcos was
re-elected but this was correct he was
the last popularly elected philippine
chief executive until 1986.
many high-level american officials
considered the philippines to be the
most serious and the most bleak threat
that we face in asia
that's a staggering statement think of
what that entails 1967 the peak of the
cultural revolution in china uh vietnam
uh
the level of sort of social instability
in asia and the national security
council is saying the philippines is
we got problems
so this is a period of immense social
upheaval
uh shortly before wright wrote this memo
marcos forces opened fire on peasant
demonstrators they were part of a
a milinerian cult armed with amulets and
uh and bolos uh not with guns and killed
33 of them in the streets of manila
uh they were protests of uh an explosive
character the first of which took place
in 66 as i'm about to deal with
it was these social tensions that tore
through the contradiction of the heart
of stalinism at the core of the pkp and
split it into two rival factions along
the fault lines of the sino-soviet
dispute
in other words
and i'll get back to this in my
conclusion but to
preview
it was not either domestic disputes or
external machinations but rather the
same heightened global social tensions
that were accelerating the sino-soviet
dispute in the core
simultaneously was producing social
unrest in countries around the world
paris of 68 etc the rise of
authoritarian regimes suharto etc
this period of revolutionary upheaval
and authoritarianism tore through
communist parties around the globe
splintering them along the fault lines
of the sino-soviet dispute it is the
shared geopolitical and global context
of class struggle and upheaval that gave
the sino-soviet dispute its
international character
the protests in the philippines
were over the course of 1966 bound up
with the question of the war in vietnam
young people in the philippines as young
people around the globe were shocked by
the televised brutality of america's war
by the hypocrisies of it
by the trampling underfoot of the uh
national sovereignty of the vietnamese
people etc all of these terms were being
widely used by young people in berkeley
california and in manila philippines
and every country in between
the pkp however
had not only supported marcos in 1965
they had quietly entered into his
cabinet members of the central committee
were working in the offices of juan
ponce enrique who was the right-hand man
of marcos
they were reluctant to break with marcos
but at the same time they needed to
retain a hold over the youth movement
their youth youth
their usefulness to the marcos
administration rested in their hold over
a mass movement if they lost their hold
of the mass movement they lost their
political value to marcos
but to retain a hold over the mass
movement increasingly required speaking
out against the war in vietnam which
required speaking out against marcos's
deployment of troops
you're caught in an insoluble conundrum
over the course of 1966 the party was
silent on the war in vietnam
and its front organizations
the young people's organization in
particular the nationalist youth
silent
they did not denounce marcos's
deployment of troops
not until october 1966
it was in august 1966
that
the battle lines for the future break
began to be drawn along the geopolitical
fault lines of the sino-soviet splint in
july of 1966 csun
a leading member of the pkp and head of
the youth organization traveled to japan
for the 12th gen suite field world
congress on atomic and hydrogen bombs
this is a fascinating historical moment
for the sino-soviet split from the
periphery in a great many countries
because it was is at this seemingly
somewhat innocuous com congress a
congress opposed to the proliferation of
nuclear weapons but that was connected
to front organizations of the japanese
communist party
that a number of delegates from a number
of countries throughout the global south
secretly entered china it was in late
july 1966 the dates are extraordinary
uh the japanese communist party as a
result of the slaughter of the pki and
what they saw is the ccp's culpability
in this
uh because the ccp had recently
instructed the japanese communist party
similarly to engage in armed conflict
uh broke with the ccp and reoriented
toward moscow refusing to accept the
chinese communist delegation to this
congress a majority of the delegations
to this congress including jomasison
walked out in protest and then secretly
traveled to beijing
they arrived in beijing on august 6 1966
the day before mao had issued his
bombard the headquarters poster at
picking university it's an extraordinary
moment it is the launching of the
cultural revolution and for two weeks as
mao met with the red guard
uh
all of the delegates of the future
representatives of the parties that
would split along the lines of the
sino-soviet dispute
were present
they were hailed as uh the revolutionary
representatives of the proletariat and
peasantry there was a gathering staged
by cho and lie on their behalf where 10
000 people gathered to celebrate them
and sang the east is red
um
it was in this moment
that i think the uh the character of
the len bial phase of maoism protracted
people's war the yanun of world
revolution and the cultural revolution
was disseminated
uh in the wake of the slaughter of the
pki
jama sisun took these ideas back to the
philippines
events came to a head when lyndon baines
johnson october 24 1966 traveled to
manila for the manila summit
the goal of this summit which was
secretly orchestrated by johnson but
presented as if it came from marcos
uh was in the words of the philippines
free press the entire firepower of the
american delegation during the summit
was concentrated on changing the
complexion of the war in vietnam
from an american war
to a war of bi and four asians the
entire thing was orchestrated by johnson
staged in the manila hotel uh the grand
dam of american colonialism on the
on the waters of manila bay and
in a bizarre and macabre coincidence an
american freighter collided with the
philippine ship the day that the manila
summit opened and uh i believe over 60
filipinos drowned and their bodies were
floating in the manila bay during the
staging of the manila bay summit outside
the macarthur windows of johnson's suite
the
uh youth
organized in the pkp around jomasison
where finally the muzzle was taken off
and there was an explosion of protest
outside the manila bay outside the
manila hotel and the manila summit and
it was brutally suppressed by the police
on orders both from marcos and from
plainclothes u.s officials
in the wake of this all of the social
tensions that had been percolating
beneath the surface emerged
the young people that were the base of
political support for joma cesar uh
were looking to continue to protest no
longer protesting the manila summit but
police brutality
um and csun needing to retain this as a
base of his own political support sought
to corral these protests behind the
program of nationalism he delivered a
speech at aponeo university on december
6 1966 in which he said there is a need
to wage a nationalist education campaign
the events before during and after the
october 24th incident reveal to us how
much our government officials
misunderstand the spirit of nationalism
anti-nationalism has so much poisoned
the minds of so many of our police
officers and those higher executive
officials who give them the orders now i
could go on in quoting the speech but
csun's point is
the po he wasn't making the classic
marxist point that the police are the
armed bodies enforcing the state which
serves the interests of the ruling class
he was saying look they've been
miseducated by anti-nationalism and we
need a nationalist education campaign so
that they understand that they have a
common set of interests with the
protesting youth
he was not and this is the critical
point instigating the leftward movement
of youth and workers he was tail ending
it he was seeking to constrain it as his
base of political support but it was
pulling him
in a particular
an increasingly radical direction
there were consequences as a result
uh an investigation into the police
brutality station the philippine
legislature very rapidly turned into an
investigation of alleged communist
influence among the protesters and
singled out was jose maria
you can see him here from the manila
chronicle where he faces prosecution
uh
the the uh
at the center of this was the man in the
black suit carmelo barbaro a man who
rose to power as a smuggler
became a legislator
and was bound up with the prosecuting of
communists and alleged communists in a
series of witch hunts in 1966
what's interesting
and i'll get back to this in two slides
what is interesting is that carmelo
barbaro while he was the leading voice
attacking
alleged communists and actual communists
sent to be a communist was a criminal
offense and to be a communist leader was
a capital offense at this point the
communist party was outlawed despite the
fact that it had been allied with the
former president and was now allied with
the current president
there was a sort of universal hypocrisy
in this game
uh carmelo barbaro the leading witch
hunter was closely tied to the opening
of ties with the soviet union
his daughter studied at patrice lumumba
university
every visiting soviet scholar that came
to the country stayed in the home of
carmelo barbaro the leading
anti-communist witch hunter
it emerged during these investigations
uh staged in the legislature that a
large contingent of students and
professors were scheduled to travel to
china here you see three editorial
cartoons november 18 november 24 and
december 10 from the manila chronicle
red china is luring filipino students
away as a pied piper the filipino
student is defying his mother the
department of foreign affairs uh the
defiance of mother is uh particularly
egregious uh on behalf of the sneaky mou
hiding behind the door and finally these
students are running roughshod
over uh the foreign office uh this is
actually rather far from the case they
have been invited their visit had been
approved uh by the marcos administration
prior to the protests of october 24 in
the wake of the protest marcos shut down
the intended travel and declared that no
one would be allowed to travel to uh
china not even tenured professors at the
various universities
but while the marcos administration was
shutting down all travel to china in
particular because of the cultural
revolution which is increasingly
becoming the world internationally was
increasingly becoming aware of the
character of the cultural revolution
the marcus administration was through
other elements in the pkp conducting
informal diplomacy with the soviet union
this man here teogosio lansang is a very
interesting figure uh in the late 1940s
he traveled to china where he was
present for the founding of the prc in
october 1949
uh he was responsible for tagalog
language broadcasts of radio pay king
before he was moved to moscow prior to
the sino-soviet split he was in the
soviet union over the course of the
sino-soviet split in the late 1950s
early 1960s his return to the
philippines in january 1967 was
orchestrated behind the scenes by the
marcos administration as a means of
opening informal diplomacy with moscow
to secure loans from the soviet union
and the eastern bloc as well as a market
for philippine sugar and other
agricultural products he was facilitated
in this by other figures william and
salia pomeroy former heads of the pkp
now in exile in london or in england and
ruben torres a figure who was
instrumental in this and played a
critical role in the marcos
administration a member of the central
committee of the communist party and
also a salaried government official in
the uh offices of juan ponce
the marcos administration had a loyal
wing of the party that was looking to
secure ties with the soviet union as
marcos was increasingly making
machinations toward military rule
in fact the party as i demonstrated in
my book drama dictatorship was
instrumental in facilitating this
the unified pkp
with these wings torn apart by diverging
social interests made one last united
attempt
at a political uh
campaign in february 1967 with the
foundation of the movement for the
advancement of nationalism man
the function of man unlike say the front
organizations of the party in labor
or in the peasants or the youth
the function of man was a relationship
between the various front organizations
of the party in these sectors
with the national bourgeoisie
with capitalist interests
this was the culmination of all of those
efforts and they worked tirelessly to
create this organization this is from
the program of the founding of man the
names are small and they wouldn't mean
much to most of the audience but if you
look through them carefully it's a very
interesting mix
it's senators
congressmen
uh neither titan tied to the communist
party in no way except by a loose
alliance
it's what would be the central committee
of the future pkp the moscow wing it's
central members founding members of the
cpp the beijing wing and its business
interests the head of a
nationwide
chain of pawn shops
workers tend to not be fond of pawn
shops but there you are pawn shops uh
and uh business interests tied to
banking etc all of them merged together
in this organization
it was in the wake of the founding of
man that the party tore itself apart
both sides made a scramble to seize
power
the cpp failed or the future cpp failed
and was expelled in april 1967.
they published a statement in the peking
review in june 9 written on may 1 that
declared mao zedong's thought lights up
the whole world committed to an
uncompromising struggle against modern
revisionism with the soviet revisionist
ruling click at its center that was the
founding principle of the cpp opposition
to modern revisionism that is to say the
line of the soviet union
the critical question
for the now expelled members around jose
maria and it wasn't simply csun there
was a sizable chunk of the party that
was expelled
in the founding of a new party was the
formation of an alliance
with a section of the ruling elite well
the section of the capitalist class this
was intrinsic to their program the block
of four classes
this was what was the critical element
prior to the founding of the cpp the pkp
had an alliance with marcos csun sought
to retain ties with marcos over the
space of about six months after the
expulsion writing a friendly letter to
the president again an event that he has
attempted to bury
eventually however
the party found new allies in particular
the figure ninoy aquino who even for
those outside philippine politics are
probably familiar with the tensions
between aquino and marcos
um
and it is here that we see another
element of the sino-soviet split and how
rivalries aligned
while figures like marcos sought to use
ties with the soviet union to
consolidate their hold on power as they
moved towards authoritarian rule in a
time of social unrest figures like
aquino on the other hand
were the excluded opposition
in a time of social unrest they too
sought dictatorship
aquino was very explicit that he would
impose martial law if he succeeded in
getting into power the problem for
aquino was he needed to be in power
first in my book the drama of
dictatorship i have referred to these
layers as the conspiring understudies
marcos is our lead actor but there are
the conspiring understudies who are
looking to remove him and play the lead
role of dictator themselves
the line of beijing at this point
armed struggle throughout the
countryside of the world but an alliance
with a section of the capitalist class
these two facets
merged in the interests of these
conspiring understudies
the rest of opposition
among the capitalist class in a time of
social upheaval it is in this context
that nino aquino facilitates the
founding of the communist party and ties
with the new people's army
uh from various uh former hook gorillas
the founding document of the party
declared armed with invincible mao
zedong thought the communist party of
the philippines will surely triumph and
the filipino people and the leadership
of the revolutionary proletariat will
achieve people's democracy first and
socialism next
it's outside the the sort of the
confines of this particular talk but my
forthcoming book the drama dictatorship
deals with the next period
1969 the founding of the cpp to the
declaration of martial law and the
machinations of the pkp the moscow party
which staged bombings on behalf of the
marcos administration to justify martial
law with the complicity of the president
and wrote the documents justifying
military dictatorship and the cpp on the
other hand which directed all of the
unrest and protests of the time behind a
canon when martial law was imposed over
60 000 people were arrested for
political reasons for the first five
years of the marcos dictatorship the
majority of these were not communists
they were not members of the political
elite they were ordinary workers and
peasants
mao however and this is my final slide
now however and the interest of the
chinese communist party because of the
heightened tensions of the sino-soviet
dispute which had turned into an armed
conflict in the xinjiang region border
borderlands of china and the soviet
union
uh
sought the support
of kissinger and nixon
as a counterweight
to
the threat of the soviet union
and reigned in london
altered the line of the party from
protracted people's war to the three
worlds theory
uh
in which the soviet union and the united
states were the two
first world powers and were the great
enemy of the peoples of the world
uh and sought to form alliances of his
own with autographs this became the
policy of the ccp
and thus
uh
with the
rise to power of pinochet and the
crushing of the chilean communist party
the chinese communist party immediately
welcomed
pinochet for the chilean communist party
and had ties
with the soviet union
in a similar fashion
uh
when marcos sought to open ties with
china in 1974
uh
mao welcome to mel de marcos september
1974. you can see him here kissing in
elder marcus's hand
uh and joe mason now head of the cpp
wrote a statement in the flagship
publication of the communist party
heralding
the visit of imelda marcos
to the chinese communist party to
beijing as a diplomatic victory for the
people's republic of china
a victory for the philippine
revolutionary struggle
in 1975 formal diplomatic ties between
the philippines and china were opened
mao met with ferdinand marcos marcus
declared while in china that he would be
crushing dissidents in the philippines
and no one in china made any attempt to
countermand him they would not intervene
in these internal affairs and thus the
pkp was now in the cabinet of the
martial law administration and the cpp
was isolated
the sino-soviet split had split the
communist party of the philippines in
two in a period of increasing social
unrest and now it was unmoored from
beijing but it was said it was set in
motion by the political line that was
articulated from 65 to 70.
by looking at the sino-soviet split from
the periphery we see a number of things
one
that it is a shared global conflict
that is leading to these tensions that
brings about a set of aligned rivalries
that this is disseminated not simply
along hub and spokes but through a mesh
of ties throughout the periphery
it also calls us to sort of reevaluate
the sort of bipolar narrative of the
cold war
ferdinand marcos was a critical ally of
washington
and yet
here we see him allied to a communist
party
and conducting informal diplomacy with
the soviet union from 1965
through the 1970s
it
indicates that to an extent the critical
question for us in understanding the
development of the sino-soviet split and
the global cold war is not to follow the
map of geopolitics but the map of the
class struggle for this i think is the
decisive question that underlies the
sign of soviet dispute and the tensions
that it gave rise to and that it
expressed thank you
thank you very much
joseph this is really a rich and
detailed discussion um a lot of
a lot of historical
episodes to explore
so i'm going to open it up now to
question and answer
i'd like to give the priority to any of
our guests who are in the philippines
right now for the first questions
because i know that it's very late there
um so if anyone
has stayed up this late um to follow the
talk i'd like to give you the first
opportunity to ask question however if
you want to wait that's fine as well but
um
the way we'll do this is you can use the
raise your hand function um and then
i'll call on you to unmute and show your
face
if you're having difficulty using that i
noticed there's a lot of people
using the phone option today if you have
a question and you can't get my
attention wait till there's a gap in the
speech and then um just
announce that you have a question but
let's start with people who may raise
their hand first does anyone want to
start us with a question now
joseph well people are waiting to
formulate their thoughts i'll start with
a question a very naive question
i'm a southeast asianist but not a
philippine scholar
and i found
your descriptions of marcos to be so
interesting you know um because
the way we
as non-experts
imagine marcos really comes as a kind of
set of caricatures in some sense right
and so i wondered if you could
tell us a little bit about what your
research tells us about marcos and the
way in which he
kind of moved
effortlessly it seems between all of
these kinds of positions that seem to be
polar opposites to the rest of us right
um
and one what does that say about marcos
as an individual but also maybe how does
that reveal something about these
binaries that we often see as so
you know such polar irreconcilable
opposites but perhaps they're not really
such opposites after all or something
like that yes it's a terrific question i
mean worthy of a talk in its own right i
suppose it's a common remark but it's
true uh
they're a a very famous filipino author
by the name of jose pete
writing i believe in 1971
characterized the um
the dispute in the elite uh
in which one camp was oriented around
marcos and another around aquino and the
opposition
uh and he said if one did have to give
this a sort of class character
one would see this as a divide between
the ongshan
and the nouveau
in the oligarchy
and leonchan is a kinowin company this
is old established money
ties to spanish colonialism american
imperialism many of them leading
collaborators during the japanese
occupation large landed estates and so
on and so forth the forces around marcos
and marcos himself and this is critical
to understanding the psychology of the
man
were
uh the nouveau riche
uh they were the new industrial
interests and so on this is not to say
that they were poorer by any means and
marcus enriched himself extraordinarily
but they were
frowned upon in the best of
circumstances by the unshown excluded
scorned lianchon and this is true of
this this sort of social layer around
the world consolidated its interest
through incestuous intermarriage uh and
sort of keeping it all within the family
etc it's a bit of a weed eater noise
outside i apologize
um
and marcos presented this
and brought
to bear in his sort of
character
the quintessence of the nouveau
self-construction
he was forever obsessed with the
creation of a persona and he was
brilliant at it he was cunning conniving
and absolutely brutal
uh one of the most famous early stories
from marcos's career is that his
father's political rival was murdered in
his home shot through his head while
brushing his teeth and marcos was
convicted of the murder
um and marcos was put on sentence
subject to life imprisonment and then
was going to be subject to the death
penalty
but he was also at the time a graduate
of the law school and was taking the bar
and while in prison and this is a
somewhat legendary story while in prison
he aced the bar
getting the number one score in the
country that year
and wrote a three volume appeal to the
supreme court asking them to throw out
the charges against him which was upheld
not so much on legal grounds but because
behind the scenes people said
it wouldn't look good to have the number
one lawyer in the country subject to the
death penalty and so a political deal
was reached and marcos was released this
was his rise to national prominence
deserved in some ways but also at the
same time revealing of the level of
brutality and machiavellianism that he
would resort to
he then concocted a persona by uh
creating a story of having medals of
honor and so on and so forth
he would turn on anyone who was not
immediately useful to him we see this
again and again and again and we see
this not only domestically but
internationally and marcos was extremely
able not simply at working with the
united states but working in the united
states is a wonderful book uh called
waltzing with the dictator by raymond
bonner that demonstrates how the marcos
knew the ins and outs of american
politics
they contributed a million dollars
stolen from the coffers of the
philippine state to the re-election of
richard nixon
amazing
um huge contributor more money went from
the philippines to richard nixon's
reelection they went from the united
states to marcosus so there's that
element and while playing that marcus
was able also to reach out to the soviet
union
i think that persona of
self-construction
uh and that willingness to do
effectively anything in his political
rise is the critical character of marcos
and the class interests he represented
thank you that's fascinating um i see
there's a hand up from
matthias fiebiger and if i've
mispronounced your name please say it
properly
sure um you got it almost right it's
fibiger um
thanks joseph for what i thought was a
really fascinating talk it inspired a
lot of questions uh from mayan but
just to limit myself to one um i wonder
if you could spend a little bit more
time explaining how the philippine
communist movement interpreted the
collapse the crushing of the indonesian
communist movement because it seems to
me that it could play out in one of two
directions on the one hand this crushing
of the pki
may discredit the parliamentary peaceful
road to socialism that had been embraced
by the pki but on the other hand it may
discredit the allegiance with beijing
that had also been embraced by the pki
so i wonder if you could just say a
little bit about how that debate
unfolded within the philippine communist
movement because this seems
fundamental to your argument and perhaps
quite contingent as well
that's a terrific question um because it
is such a critical question for every
communist party as i mentioned in
passing the japanese communist party had
to grapple with this question that
precipitated the shift in their
allegiance this was true for every
communist party around the globe uh
the events in indonesia were absolutely
shocking and required
an assessment
um
internally the discussions within the
pkp
likely polarized around
opposition to beijing on the one hand
and the need to follow the line of
moscow so there was that but publicly
it was
written by csun himself who became the
head of the beijing party csun with the
beijing oriented party csun wrote a a
statement assessing the events in
indonesia which he published in the
mainstream press in the leading news
weekly of the philippines the
philippines free press
in 1966
he had a sense of the scale of what had
occurred in indonesia he referred to
nearly a million dead
and then he wrote a political assessment
and
his political assessment was
that this was the opening of a
revolutionary period in indonesia
an extraordinary claim
historically seen
uh but one in keeping with the sort of
voluntarism of maoism uh you know the
paper tigers and whatnot uh sort of it's
all in the willpower and
his claim was
that for every dead indonesian communist
there were four aggrieved family members
and friends who would rise up
and
that in taking power in a sution and
suharto
had made several critical mistakes
and among those
he claimed they had alienated certain
layers of the national bourgeoisie who
had been tied to sukarna again that that
that class the national bourgeoisie that
faction of the capitalist class
and as a result
these layers would be driven to arm's
struggle
csun genuinely thought in 1966 in the
middle of 1966 with nearly a million
dead members of the pki
that quote the struggle for power in
indonesia is far from over
one doesn't forget a line like that
the struggle for power in indonesia was
over for a very long time
i did not really re-emerge until the
1990s why might say and when it did
there was not a communist party on the
landscape to speak up
csun's argument however was in keeping
with the perspective of the cpp
which he founded in 6869
which claimed
martial law is good for revolution
fascist dictatorship is good for
revolution
this remains the line of the party
uh i gave a lecture in march at berkeley
on the subject of a bombing in the
philippines in 1971 analyzed the events
and its significance and at the time i
was denounced furiously by the by the
communist party of the philippines and
by jomah cecil
and csun made a speech the week that i
gave my lecture in which he said and i
quote
the best thing that can happen for the
philippine revolution is for duterte to
impose a fascist dictatorship
he will be finished in a year or two
this there's a continuity here
repression breeds resistance and so the
line of csun and the formative layers of
the cpp was that the repression in
indonesia would foment and accelerate a
revolutionary upheaval
it's a
fundamentally bankrupt perspective uh in
my opinion and one that
in some ways says that the best
communist is a dead communist it's a
terrifying perspective but that was the
response to the events in 6566 in the
philippines
uh we have a question from
adrian vergara
can you hear me
yes we can hear you great good afternoon
to everyone i'm actually from i'm
actually a graduate student from the
philippines and
i recently read dr scalise's work uh
earlier earlier this year it's his
dissertation
sorry i want to jump in i'm having
trouble hearing you uh is it possible to
get a little closer to the mic perhaps
okay okay uh can you hear me now yes
thank you yeah
so i read your dissertation earlier this
year
my question is less about the
presentation and more about your
scholarship on on the philippine
communist movement as a whole
because recently
i'm sure you're aware of rigoberto
tiglao i have seen him selectively cite
the research to push forward certain
narratives that justice just that
justifies martial law how do you feel
about jesus a scholar and
as a scholar
how does one defend his work against
against the co-optation to promote
certain narratives that
justifies
authoritarianism yes
thank you very much for that question
let me let me explain the context of the
question for the larger audience and
then respond to it i but i appreciate
this opportunity to uh present my own
perspective uh as it's a critical
question
um
history
in any country has profound resonances
but seldom is that quite as clear as in
the philippines around the question of
martial law the question which will not
go away uh particularly with the rise of
duterte
now
uh a former leading member of the
communist party
named bobby teglau he was the head of
the manila rizal regional council of the
communist party in the 19th early 1970s
uh subsequently broke with the party
became ambassador to greece under the
arroyo administration and then
a very prominent
apologist for the duterte administration
on the front page of the manila times
over the course of the last four or five
years
um
this another point that i guess should
be made for an international audience uh
the character of the duterte
administration has been one of unbridled
authoritarianism and death squads
uh the estimates are hard to come by but
it seems likely that over 30 000 people
have been killed by the death squads
unleashed by the duterte administration
since 2016 a staggering figure one that
uh
begins to raise questions of genocide uh
it's it is an extraordinary figure
uh and diglow uh drawing on my doctoral
dissertation which he cited on the front
page of the times in a series on the
so-called scalise revelations
uh
cited my scholarship
and pointed out
correctly that i had highlighted a
relationship
between ninoy aquino the opposition
figure and the communist party
and included concluded
fundamentally twisting my analysis that
martial law was therefore warranted and
justified
uh something that i have fundamentally
opposed anyone who reads my scholarship
knows that i respond with horror to the
martial law administration uh and that
my scholarship is dedicated
to a remarkable extent for a scholar to
trying to use history as a means of
preventing the recurrence of such
events
um i have repeatedly spoken out against
this on facebook and so on uh i don't
have a front page column in the manila
times with which to trumpet my
perspective
uh but i published a statement that was
widely circulated just a couple days ago
because diglao was once again coming to
the fore
because bongbong marcos ferdinand marcos
jr has effectively announced his
candidacy for president of the
philippines
and
is
terrifying to say a viable candidate
uh in the sense of could get elected
and one of the key components
of
the social media launch of his campaign
was to misuse my doctoral dissertation
uh to claim that martial law was
warranted
no scholar wants to be in such a
position my doctoral dissertation has
now been downloaded almost 15 000 times
for very
very strange reasons
so allow me to respond having created
the context i fundamentally
and
without any reservation denounce the mis
use of my scholarship
uh to in any way claim that martial law
was justified what diglow scandalously
leaves out
is that marcos was himself allied to a
communist party
and that's a critical element of my
analysis
uh and then attempts to twist this into
a justification for military
dictatorship
my entire argument is how dictatorship
can be avoided
and my point is that the two rival
communist parties allied with the rival
contenders for the throne
subordinate the entire movement and
defense of democracy
behind the aspirants to dictatorship
it was this this defusal and betrayal
of the movement for the defense of
democracy behind anti-democratic forces
that in the end made martial law
possible
to oppose the threat of dictatorship i
would argue there is the need for the
political independence of workers from
every layer that's looking to coordinate
some new form of authoritarianism and
that is my response to diglaw and the
apologists for marcos and thanks for the
chance to clarify that
thank you for that clear response in the
context it's fascinating and
clearly uh at the center of a lot of
discussion in the contemporary
philippines yes does anyone want to
ask any further questions